SPYING ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> HE'S DRAWING A CONCLUSION.
IS THERE ANYTHING WRONG WITH
THIS FBI INFORMANT?
THEY DID WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO DO AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AGREE.
AND OF COURSE TREY GOWDY KNOWS
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AGREE
BECAUSE NOBODY SPEAKS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE LIKE TREY GOWDY.
DID THEY HAVE AN INFORMANT, AKA,
SPY, AT THE DNC TO CHASE DOWN
THE RUSSIANS HACKING THE DNC'S
E-MAILS?
NO.
IF THEY'RE TRYING TO PROTECT US
AND THE CANDIDATES AND THE
ELECTION FROM THE RUSSIANS WHERE
WEREN'T THERE INFORMANTS IN JILL
STEIN'S CAMPAIGN OR HILLARY
CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN?
>> Sean: BOOM, CHECK MATE.
WE HAVE OUR FINANCE
WE HAVE OUR FINANCE   -
WE HAVE OUR FINANCE   --
WE HAVE OUR FINANCE   -- F
WE HAVE OUR FINANCE   -- FOX
WE HAVE OUR FINANCE   -- FOX N
WE HAVE OUR FINANCE   -- FOX NEW
WE HAVE OUR FINANCE   -- FOX NES
CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR AND LET
ME START WITH THE RESPONSE TO
TREY GOWDY.
WHY WEREN'T THERE SPIES IN THE
OTHER CAMPAIGNS AND CHRIS STEEL
SAID IT'S 50/50 USED TO GET FISA
WARRANTS ON AMERICAN CITIZENS
ONE THAT HAPPENED TO BE IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> THERE WEREN'T SPIES IN OTHER
CAMPAIGNS, SEAN, BECAUSE THEY
WERE SPYING ON TRUMP NOT THE
RUSSIANS.
THIS IS -- I DON'T KNOW IF TREY
GOWDY WAFTED A LITTLE BIT --
>> Sean: HE NEVER SAW THE
DOCUMENTS.
HOW COULD ME MAKE THAT
DOCUMENT --
>> BUT ME MADE A COMMENT SO
IRRESPONSIBLE HE SAID AMERICANS
SHOULD BE CONFIDENT THE FBI
WORKED THE CASE AS THEY SHOULD
HAVE.
THEN WHY DID THEY HIDE IT FROM
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT FOR
EIGHT MONTHS WHEN THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO BRIEF THEM QUARTERLY
WHILE THEY LEAKED THE  EXISTENCE
TO THE NEW YORK TIMES.
>> Sean: EVERYTHING THE NEW YORK
TIMES REPORTING HAS NOW
BOOMERANGED EVEN WITHIN THEIR
OWN REPORTS.
THEY WERE REVEALING INFORMATION
THEY DIDN'T MEAN TO REVEAL.
DR. GORKA, I THINK OTHER THINGS
ARE BACKFIRING ON THEM AS WELL.
>> IT'S THE ULTIMATE BOOMERANG.
LOOK AT THE VIDEO OF BEN RHODES
AND YOU'LL UNDERSTAND
EVERYTHING.
THE NIGHT OF THE ELECTION, BEN
RHODES THE MASTER OF LYING, HAS
NO WORDS TO EXPLAIN THE LOSS OF
HILLARY CLINTON.
THIS IS WHY THEY WERE DOING WHAT
THEY WERE DOING.
SHE HAD TO WIN AT ALL COSTS.
THAT'S WHY AN INTELLIGENCE IS --
ASSET WITH US PUT IN THE
CAMPAIGN LET'S NOT ARGUE WHETHER
IT'S A SPY OR INFORMANT.
WE NEED ONE ANSWER TO ONE
QUESTION, WHY WAS THE OPERATION
STARTED?
WE STILL DON'T KNOW?
AN AUSTRALIAN EMBASSY AND NOW A
MALTESE PROFESSOR IN ROME AND
TREY GOWDY THE DOCUMENTS.
>> Sean: THE FIX SIN FOR HILARY.
SHE DOESN'T OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BUT
MARTHA STEWART DID.
DO WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW, LOOK AT MASKING AND
INTELLIGENCE AND FIXING THE
HILARY CAMPAIGN.
FISA ABUSE.
IT'S ROTTING FROM THE HEAD DOWN
AND THE FBI RANK AND FILE WILL
EXPOSE IT.
THIS DOVETAILS NICELY THE WHOLE
McCABE MEMO AND FIRST OF ALL THE
PRESIDENT COULD FIRE COMEY
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T LIKE THE COLOR
OF HIS SOCKS.
HE DIDN'T NEED A REASON BUT WHEN
YOU ADD THAT TO WHAT JOHN
SOLOMON WHAT HE IS SAYING, FBI
DOCUMENTS BRINGING IT RIGHT TO
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
AND I'VE SEEN MORE THAN I CAN
SAY.
>> PETER STRZOK SENT A TEXT
MESSAGE TO HIS MISTRESS, LISA
PAGE, AUGUST 5.
HE JUST SIGNED THE DOCUMENTS
OPENING THE TRUMP RUSSIAN
COLLUSION CASE AND IN THAT TEXT
HE SAID THE WHITE HOUSE IS
RUNNING THIS.
THE CHRONOLOGY OF EVENTS TELLS
YOU WHAT HAPPENED.
WE'RE GOING SEE A PETER STRZOK
MEMO, THE GUY WHO WROTE THE
EXONERATION TO HILARY BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION, SIGNED THE
PAPERS, AND SAID THE WHITE HOUSE
IS RUNNING THIS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA IS BEING BRIEFED
ALL THE TIME BY JOHN BRENNAN,
THE CIA DIRECTOR THE INSTITUTER
OF THE PHONY DOSSIER.
>> Sean: ANOTHER BIG REVEAL BY
THE NEW YORK TIMES AND OH, FOR
THE FBI TO INTERVIEW THIS
AUSTRALIAN THAT WAS DRINKING
WITH TO THE FOUNDER HAD TO BE
NEGOTIATE OUR STATE DEPARTMENT.
THAT MEANS JOHN KERRY KNEW.
THAT MEANS PROBABLY OBAMA KNEW.
IT'S ANOTHER SIGN POINTING TO
BARACK OBAMA AND COMPANY.
>> AFTER THE FIRST DOS
>> AFTER THE FIRST DOSSIER'S
FIRST MEMO THEY MEET ON THE
PHONY EVIDENCE.
THREE WEEKS LATER THE FBI OPENS
ITS INVESTIGATION AND ONLY
THEREAFTER DO THEY START LOOKING
>> Sean: AND NOW WE KNOW THE
TIME LINE IS OFF.
LAST WORD FROM DAN AND DR.
GORKA.
>> I THINK THE NEXT SHOE TO DROP
IS THE INFORMATION ON RUSSIAN
DIRT ON HILARY WAS CLEARED OUT
AND WHO PISHTD
AND WHO PISHT
AND WHO PUSHT
AND WHO PUSHE
AND WHO PUSHED
AND WHO PUSHED I
AND WHO PUSHED IT
AND WHO PUSHED IT I
AND WHO PUSHED IT IN
AND WHO PUSHED IT IN A
AND WHO PUSHED IT IN AND
AND WHO PUSHED IT IN AND T
AND WHO PUSHED IT IN AND THA
AND WHO PUSHED IT IN AND THAT
WILL WILL BE NEXT SHOE TO DROP.
>> Sean: DR. GORKA.
>> SUSPECT NUMBER ONE IS JOHN
BRENNAN AND HE WOULDN'T HAVE
MOVED A MUSCLE UNLESS OBAMA KNEW
AS WELL.
>> Sean: BOOM.
OKAY.
IT'S ALL COLLAPSING AND THEY ARE
TURNING ON EACH OTHER.
McCABE, COMEY.
IT WILL BE A CIRCULAR FIRING